[Music]
this week on Q&A television personality
Ilona man coughs key host of the Ilona
show seen on Rt
a Russian government-funded television
station streaming live and broadcasting
in over 100 countries worldwide
[Music]
Ilana Minkowski what is the Ilona show
the alone a show at this point has
almost become an extension of myself
whereas at first it was a it was a
project and it was go make a TV show now
it really has become I think V alone a
show and the it embodies my passions the
things that I really feel deserve to be
top news in the you know in the world
especially in the u.s. too because we do
focus on domestic politics on US
politics and so the primary goal is to
offer an alternative to the mainstream
media because there's just I'm sorry
there's just so much garbage out there
that you want somebody who can weed
through it who's not just going to go
through the basic DC back-and-forth talk
that you have about who said what in
terms of Eric Cantor and John Boehner
there are larger stories out there
including the numerous wars that our
country is involved in including the
economic situation and I think that
somebody people want somebody who is
willing to actually talk about that in a
big picture to connect the dots and I'm
hoping that I'm providing that for
people and especially for a younger
audience I think the Ilona show is the
new generation of what news is in the
sense that it's not dry it's not stodgy
it's it's witty it's sarcastic and so
you're entertained but you're also being
informed and you're learning something
you're not being dumbed down the way
that I think that a lot of the other
news does okay where can I see it well
you can watch RT we are on cable in
almost every single or every major city
in the US I know that we're on cable in
New York in DC in Chicago Los Angeles
San Francisco and
I believe maybe North or South Carolina
something like 20 to 22 million
households now within the u.s. can
access our tea on cable around the world
were on satellite you can always watch
us online the alone a show has its own
YouTube channel you can go to the rt.com
website and we livestream everything so
there are a lot of options out there if
you want to find it how long have you
been doing it the show itself or working
at RT either one I've been working at
our TV for about two and a half years
the show we went live I think it was
January 21st of last year so it's been
about a year and a half and prior to
that we had a few months about two and a
half months where it was in an
experimental phase we were taping the
show it was 30 minutes we did it
twice a week then we started three times
a week then I went to five days a week
and then boom we started going live for
an hour every day we have some tape of
you on that first show let's let's just
film it's it's short it's only 40 second
let's watch
welcome to the alone a show I'm a low
demand costs key and this is episode one
of a brand-spankin'-new experience
coming straight out of Washington DC now
I'm not from here myself I came out from
California to really take a fresh glance
at the Beltway politics to really see
how things work around here and try to
stir it up a little bit because there's
so much that goes on that nobody else
bothers to share so I'm here to find
that and to give you something different
so if you're sick are the same old
stories if you're sick of dancing around
all of the real issues and the Ilona
show is the place for you you know in
one of the blogs a couple of months ago
you wrote this so we'll get into the
some of your background there are those
in this world who can't look past the
name and funding of where I work and
assume that I'm a Russian propagandist
who gets my scripts straight from the
Kremlin only after I finish our
obligatory morning session of worshiping
a bare-chested picture of Putin how
often do you get that and explain RT
used to stand for Russia today house how
does that Network work you know I can't
say that I mean that when I was blogging
there was just blogging a Radley Balko
blog the agitator and so that was my
little introduction there where I
decided to to play with it to make fun
of some of the critique that we get
because yes Artie did it stands for
Russia today now we just go by Artie
it's a it's cleaner it's more simple and
you know for me part of that is just
being able to laugh at that critique
because I don't feel like it's really a
valid one I do believe that people are
afraid when they see somebody else and I
think you know we've seen this from
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton who
has mentioned Artie we've seen this from
the broadcasting Board of Governors as
they really see this as a competition
and they're saying that we're losing to
the Russians and they can't believe that
it's happening you know on their own
turf here in the US but for me I'm an
American so anytime I hear that
criticism the I somehow an M
anti-american and I work for a
propaganda machine that works against
this government I have to laugh at it
because otherwise it really gets my
blood boiling because I am an American
I love this country and I feel that it's
my duty I would even go as far as
calling it my patriotic duty to really
report on what's happening here on the
real issues that that I feel like our
mainstream media really is happy to
close their eyes to is really happy to
try to blind the eyes of the masses as
well because I feel like they have
become this body that works for the
government there are a lapdog of the
government instead of a watchdog of the
government these days so somebody's got
to do it and it's embarrassing I think
for US media if RT is doing a much
better job at exposing some of the
hypocrisy and the corruption and the
wrongdoing what's going on here who owns
RT RT is publicly funded so it's funded
by the Russian government why did he do
it you know you know you would have to
ask them and how did you get involved in
it I was in Moscow one summer I have a
lot of family that still lives in Moscow
and so I had been working there and had
been introduced to RT and at that point
I was still in college still thinking of
what I might do after I graduate and had
always been interested in journalism and
decided to intern at the channel and
just check it out now where were you in
college I was going to UC Santa Cruz UC
Santa Cruz on banana slug that's a
school in Northern California which is a
has a very mellow hippie vibe I guess
you could say and which really made me
realize that I lived in another world
growing up when I came here to
Washington DC I never realized that I
would be such a goober crazy lefty until
I moved here because I thought that that
was absolutely normal but so at that
point you know I interned at RT I was
really interested in what they were
doing but all of their offices were
still in Russia and I wasn't prepared to
move back there and then once I did
graduate from university they had
already opened up offices here and so I
decided to contact them seeing if they
are interested if they need people and
from there just kind of you know it all
went the usual route emails phone calls
interviews and it happened what did you
major in
I majored in political science although
at Santa Cruz because they like to be
different they just called it
politics and I minored in film and
digital media where you were born though
in Moscow I was born in Moscow and I
moved to the state's when I was four and
you have a kind of a famous mother I do
have kind of a famous mother that's
right she is a three-time Olympic gold
medalist she was a pair of skater and
it's something that is you know brings a
lot of a lot of joy to my heart of
course it's something that I'm very
proud of but both my parents are
incredible people my mother was figure
skater she now is actually involved in
politics and Russia she's now in the
Duma
my father is an entrepreneur he was a
trained architect but he's done
everything from that design to film
production as well so on all they're
both incredibly inspiring people that
have you know helped me every step of
the way become Who I am so she's a part
of the Russian legislature she is now
yes she's the part of the Duma how did
you get to the States and what year did
you come here and why we came in 1990
and each my mother at that point was
done figure skating but she was coaching
and so we moved to Lake Arrowhead
California which was a tiny town in the
mountains but where they happen to have
an international training center where
you know Michelle Kwan and people like
that skated carlo Fosse coached there so
it was this small little nook in
Southern California where you just had
an immense amount of talent but I think
that my father always wanted to move to
the States so that was a obviously a
decision I didn't have any part of I was
four years old but I couldn't be happier
that they made it and how would you
define your politics yeah you are
American citizen yes and how would you
define your politics well I guess you
know I would call myself liberal but I
have absolutely no problem saying that
and I am a registered Democrat I voted
Democratic in the last election but feel
like the longer that I've been here in
Washington the more disenchanted I am
with the political system and with both
parties and that's something that we
really try to do on the show too is step
above that fray because
I feel like there is such an effort in
this country by politicians by the media
as well to convince people that we're so
polarized that we're so different and we
can never see eye-to-eye but there's so
much that Americans have in common with
each other but they're being distracted
by you could say wedge issues you know
things like abortion or or gay marriage
which I mean both to me are incredibly
important issues to me gay marriage and
gay rights are those that's like the
civil rights fight of my generation I
think you could say so they definitely
are important issues but I think that
it's a way to divide people to try to
distract them so they don't realize that
there is this is becoming a corporate
state that both parties no longer work
for the people but both Republicans and
Democrats are slaves to a
military-industrial complex their slaves
to Wall Street are slaves to
corporations that really control
everything and have such a strong and
very expensive grasp on it if you live
in Washington and I do in this area you
can watch Russia today RT 24 hours a day
seven days a week
your program every night six o'clock ten
o'clock one hour yes is it hard to do a
one-hour television show every day it's
it's hard in the sense that you know
there are some days when I don't want to
be on TV there are some days when you
just don't feel like having to go on TV
and put on a show for people and it's a
lot of stress because no matter what
happens you come in that morning and you
know that I have to fill an hour of TV
and it has to start at 6:00 p.m. and
there are no ways around it that's what
happens when you do a live program is
you just have to roll with the punches
and see what happens but I really love
what I do I love the team that I work
with and so we do come in excited every
day thinking of what what the material
is that we're going to put together what
we're going to put out there and of
course you know always hoping that the
people are going to notice because we're
doing it better than the other stations
out there let's watch you and a little
comment on Sarah Palin let's do it now
you know what I really love about this
is you'll see pundits
anchors or hosts on the cable networks
all talk about how Sarah Palin is such a
huge distraction plus just so unfair
that the real presidential candidates
out there have their stars dimmed by
such a money-grubbing media [ __ ] okay
maybe they don't use those exact words
but I will anyway the point is that it's
the weakest and lamest excuse for
analysis that I've ever seen here's an
idea
you don't have to cover her if you don't
want to and then you can focus on those
others suppose in real candidates and I
know I know it's really some
groundbreaking logic that I'm bestowing
upon you so I'll give it a little time
to sink it but when you wake up from
your Sarah Palin wet dream let's
remember that there's that whole
economic crisis in this country there's
a recession high unemployment a
demolished housing market how about the
fact that we are out of money
money-grubbing media [ __ ] yeah you had
to get my foul-mouthed ways there didn't
you well no you wouldn't would you hear
that on an American no I don't think you
would here I tell you where I think you
could hear that which is a place where I
draw some inspiration from as I think
that you would hear that from Jon
Stewart and I think you would hear that
from Stephen Colbert and I think that
those are the the venues where people
are really flocking to because you want
somebody who has an edge to them to talk
about the news and if specially if
you're going to make fun of the news and
how seriously they try to take
themselves then people it's fine to be I
think a little crass sometimes satire
goes a long way
like I said wit goes a long way and I
especially think that that's what
younger people want and because it's no
longer it's not the Katie Couric's I'm
sorry but people like heard they get
these multi-million dollar contracts to
host the evening news but nobody gathers
around the the the TV every night with
their families anymore to watch the
evening news and if they do it's
definitely not my generation I think you
can blame some of that on the fact that
well this is a different world we have
DVR everyone's lies are so much more
hectic and so much busier and you have
the internet you can watch whenever it's
convenient for you but I also think
people are tired of it and let me go
back to you know a point that I was
making earlier there is that I do feel
like there is this deliberate effort to
dumb television down for the audio
and I don't think that that's what they
want and I think that they want to be
spoken to like there are like there were
the audience like they're on the same
intellectual level as you and that's why
wit and satire is funny because they
feel like they're being challenged as
well as entertained as well as they're
learning something rather than just
hearing this mind boggling Casey Anthony
yada-yada-yada go on and on and on tool
time
what is tool time and it was that your
name for a tool time well I have to I
have to admit I don't know if I'm gonna
get sued for this or something but I
definitely watched what was the show
with Tim Allen when I was a I was a kid
I've completely forgotten about it now
but they had a fake show called tool
time he and his partner and so that name
just kind of rang a bell and we were
trying to think of a segment that we
could brand that we knew we could do
every single day because there's always
going to be someone new to make fun of
because of a gaffe that they made or
because of a stance that they took
that's completely hypocritical and so
tool time has become a treasured
favorite I think of the aloneness show
because it's really a moment where we
get to have fun and there's a lot of
people out there that stick their foot
in their mouth and thanks to the fact
that everything is recorded these days
you can always find a good clip of it
how long do you make that how long is
the tool time segment of the show it
varies but maybe between you know two
and a half two to four minutes every day
here's a minute of one of your two okay
let's take a look at this info that we
found today see for all of 2010 members
the house were only in session for a
hundred and twenty-one days on the
Senate 159 days that's less than half
the year so far this year and by the way
this year will be the half half over by
tomorrow the house has worked 75 days
and the Senate only 76 so where can I
sign up for this job you make around one
hundred and seventy thousand dollars a
year you only have to come to the office
half the time I want to illustrate my
point even more Senate was scheduled to
be out of session next week and then go
on recess for an entire month starting
August 6 and the House of
Representatives has been off eight weeks
already this year including this week
did you get eight weeks
vacation so far this year because I sure
did it so how the hell is Washington
supposed to solve any problems when
nobody works that's why we haven't
passed a budget and so long that's why
we are giving the 112 US Congress our
tool time award for being absolutely
useless some would say that that we're
better off as a country if they're not
in session and they would say that why
because then they're just engaged and
too much of politics or spending too
much money
well of course spending money is their
job and I'm I'm definitely in agreeance
that Congress spends a little too much
money but as long as you're here then at
least do something the weather the way
that they're really spending a lot of
money is when they sit around and they
don't actually pass any legislation
because it's all about grandstanding and
and refusing to compromise and
pretending like you have some serious
principles but then you go through and
have back to our meetings and you maybe
make some deals here and there but then
you go back out to the public and you
pretend like you're still standing your
ground whereas really you're making a
deal that completely goes against like I
said what those principles are it's just
so much back and forth and nothing is
getting done in this country and again I
feel like a lot of that is an act and
that's when it really becomes a waste of
money it becomes completely unfair to
Americans because we voted these people
into office we voted for you to
represent our interests and they're not
doing that a they're not working all
that long and whenever they are home
maybe they meet with a few constituents
but it's what they do here in Washington
that really matters because this is
where the deals are made this is where
the legislation is written where it's
signed where it's voted on this is the
center of power and if they're just
sitting around behind closed doors like
I say collecting money from lobbyists
and making all these backhanded deals
but then coming out and giving a lovely
speech to the public pretending that
they're still on their side you got to
call them out for it now you said early
in our discussion that this show is
really for younger people or at least
you were you think about it yet can I
guess that you're in your 20s higher
although even let you in on even more of
a secret I'm 25 are you the youngest
person to do a national television show
then you know I don't even know I've
actually never looked into it of you
know but I was just thinking here trying
to think of others I mean Rachel Maddow
is only an early thirties I believe but
I don't know of anybody that's that your
age and you do give your opinions on
purpose I mean that's all part of the
plan
yes it's all part of the plan I don't
pretend like our show is a straight hour
of news by any means it's called the
alone a show it's a personality centric
show and it's well I do feel that we are
we're reporting on stories what I do
offer is analysis so it is my opinion
that's interjected in there and I don't
I don't mask that at all go back to
where you learned what you think I mean
where did it start for you when did you
get actor where I learned what I think I
think it's something that that develops
your whole life
when did it start do you think for you
in terms of being politically being
politically aware inand who influenced
you you know I have to say that I
traveled all my life thanks to my family
I have seen a lot of the world and since
the sense of very early age give us an
idea that's something i you know i i've
maybe visited 20 or so countries when i
was younger we were going all over
europe I've been to a million island
countries I've been to Japan I've been
to Brazil Argentina because your momma
said okay this is both traveling with my
mother and traveling with my father who
loves to travel and was always trying to
open my eyes to the world and so that I
think first just started affecting me I
also I studied abroad and I lived in
Barcelona for four months while I was in
university I lived in Florence for four
months that really starts to hit you
when you see a different world out there
when you start talking to people in
other countries and you realize that
their perceptions matter and you start
to think of the way that they really see
your country the way that they start to
see America the way they see politics in
general and then the entire dynamics of
the world so I think that that really
wakes you up and makes you start to be
curious about it
also you know from my generation I was
14 years old on 9/11 I was in boarding
school and that was a really odd moment
for me because even though I wouldn't
call myself as someone who had been
sheltered or naive I didn't know what
terrorism was I had no idea I didn't
know what al-qaeda or the Taliban were
and and and suddenly we're fighting wars
on behalf of this country just to fight
this giant threat and so I've grown up
in this society where we're always at
war and there's always this supposed
fear of terrorism and I just don't think
that it's right I think that young
people need to be shaken out of that
because it's not it's not normal to be a
constant war that is not a way to
conduct your affairs that's not a way to
try to be a world leader and I think
that there are a lot of people at my age
that just haven't really known it to be
any different so you need to start
realizing that these things can change
that you need to stand up and you need
to speak out against it and go out and
protest and write your Congress members
and do whatever it takes but this can
stop America doesn't have to be on this
constant spiral where we are using our
counterterrorism policies and strategies
worldwide Russia today RT is seen around
the world yes is your program yes it is
so in other words when you do your
program live at six o'clock around the
network around the world runs it my the
the my program runs live from 6:00 to
7:00 p.m. and we repeat like you said at
10:00 p.m. and it's that 10:00 p.m.
repeat that goes live so for example I
know that it's it's on at 7:00 o'clock
in the morning in Moscow because that's
where I have some family members so what
do they do in Moscow do they translate
I know it's still all in English the
channel is because it's meant for an
international audience it's meant for
the entire world to see it's it's in
English just the way you know the BBC or
Al Jazeera English's because that is the
dominant language where does RT have
studios in the world RT has we have a
studio here in Washington in New York in
Miami in Los Angeles we have our studio
in Moscow there are views
bureaus in policing in Georgia in London
we have a reporter as well and in
Ukraine I know that we have a reporter
too and in India weird it might be a few
that I know that I'm missing too because
there are also arty Spanish and there's
arty Arabic how much reaction do you
personally get from doing this show from
who just around the world I mean well
how do you how do you know anybody's
watching that's a very good question
because sometimes you you start to
wonder right you're wondering how many
people are really watching first of all
we get a lot of reaction from people
online a lot of our audience comes from
YouTube because of the fact that it's
broadcast worldwide and it's because
it's much more convenient and let people
do indeed watch online you know on
Facebook I get a million messages from
people all the time that are from all
over the world and that that makes me
feel good because you know in one day
I'll get a message from somebody in
India and somebody in Australia and
somebody in London people contact us on
Twitter all the time so now we have a
dialogue going constantly and so we know
that there are other people that are
clued in that are plugged in too I mean
let's face it these days you have to
constantly be plugged in you have to be
following the news every second because
it's developing every single second on
Twitter and you always have to be
watching and our audience is - because
they're always responding to us so what
about reaction from people that watch it
just say in the Washington area I mean
if you're on cable here or you can get
it over the air but most people get it
on cable you're on there with nine other
international networks you know it's
channelled to 80 all the way up to two
what is it no it's to 71 we're to 74 but
yeah somewhere in that area there's a
number of you get reactions here in town
yes there's a lot of reaction here in
town I complain about your positions on
things can you complain oh yeah
well sure I mean it depends on who it is
and whether some people the whole point
is I bring them on my show so they can
complain about my position on things so
we can have a good honest debate about
it and you know maybe yell at each other
for a few minutes and then see if
anybody if anybody wins here but I think
the the fact that people want to come on
show is a testament to the fact that
they're paying attention that they're
interested that we have you know we have
members of Congress like Dennis Kucinich
representative Keith Ellison was just on
the show the other day Ron Paul talks to
our channal often that to me is a
testament that people in Washington are
starting to pay attention
like I said Hillary Clinton has has
mentioned the broadcasting Board of
Governors have mentioned I think we're
definitely definitely on the radar here
and you have a fellow on there named Tom
Hartman Tom Hartman also does a program
yes American there used to be an Oregon
he's now moved in this area I guess he's
based here now doing a show here yes he
does the show here he still does a radio
show which amazes me how he fits all
that into one day but he still does a
radio show every day and also the
one-hour TV show there's something
called crosstalk with Peter LaValle
Peter LaBelle is he's in Moscow but he's
an American
Peter Bell is an American yeah I've I've
never met him so I don't know too much
about him but he lives in Moscow and
what's the rest of the day on Artie what
kind of things can people see well
depends where our Bureau is here now in
Washington DC's we are arty America so
we focus on US politics on domestic
politics and in Moscow that's arty
international and so they switch off
because Moscow is running 24 hours a day
and our newscast doesn't start here
until 4 p.m. and it runs until 8:30 p.m.
at which point after that my show and
Tom Hartman's show repeat so you can
watch us specifically in the evening but
at any other time you'll see RT
international line you're 25 years old
and you've now done this to you well the
reason I do is that how did they know
had you done television before this no
how did they know that you could do this
how did they test you that's a good
question I I I'm very thankful that they
decided to test me by giving me a show
and putting so much responsibility in my
hands and really taking a chance on me
but prior to hosting the show I
been a correspondent for the channel for
a couple of months so I was already
doing live hit so I was traveling and
doing stories but the you know I also we
did a pilot because I think that people
saw that maybe I have a little more to
offer than just going out and reporting
straight stories because I love I love
the human interaction I love
interviewing people I also obviously
love to speak my mind and get deeper
into those issues and so I think that my
boss and the superiors of my channel
really saw some kind of something in me
that they thought maybe people would
like maybe people would relate to and
that I guess I could carry it so who
runs the whole shebang and out of Moscow
who runs the whole shebang out of Moscow
we have a you know a a chief margarita C
Mon yon she she runs the entire
operation here we also have my boss who
runs our editorial side in Washington DC
but can't say that I have a whole lot of
contact with I see a lot of women you
see a lot of women younger people a lot
of younger people the entire channel it
has a lot of younger people on it and I
think they're really smart and doing
that I think that they've brought in a
lot of people with fresh ideas that like
I said I know that my audience isn't all
young people I'm not only directing my
show towards a younger audience I know
that there is an older audience out
there and you told me yourself that you
watch the show if I watch it's not a
young audience alright you know so
that's a pleasure too but I think that
the whole point is that we're willing to
step outside the box they're willing to
try something different to figure out
how to make TV news exciting and
entertaining and informative again
rather than I'm sorry but like I said
the garbage that really it's a dwindled
down to be here's some more of your show
we were talking about Afghanistan
welcome to tonight's fireside Friday's
with your host alone among cops key
while President Obama is meeting with
world leaders in Portugal discussing the
war in Afghanistan with the US
military's deploying a company of m1
Abrams tanks two Marines stationed in
the northern Helmand province now let's
get one thing clear first these aren't
just any tanks no these things are
monstrosity they each weigh 68 tons
they're propelled by a jet engine and
they're equipped with 30 year old
precision firepower so why in a
mountainous dusty country like
Afghanistan would you try to have big
tanks rolling around well if you listen
to military officials they'll tell you
that it's simple aah shock and firepower
it's all part of the campaign to show
how strongly they've been beefing up
military operations and not the
unconventional counterinsurgency type no
I'm talking very conventional warfare
bomb and kill shock and awe forget about
hearts and minds cope you call that
segment fireside Fridays what's that
about
fireside Fridays is my chance
every Friday I'll pick something that
something about them that we may have
been reporting throughout the week and
maybe I want to wrap up on it or it's
just something where I want to take out
a personal moment just between myself
and the audience without a guest where I
want to highlight an issue that I feel
really passionately about and it's
supposed to be a little bit more of this
warm fuzzy setting it's I'm gonna
realize that it's cheesy we have a fake
fireplace we have fun with it and you
know it's something that I really I
think a lot about every week it's I take
my time writing it because it's really
something like I said that I feel
passionately about and the war in
Afghanistan if you watch the program
you'll notice is something that we cover
constantly let's do another clip on the
Afghanistan and you refer to the Soviets
not winning there also so just how long
will this war last Obama says that he's
going to start true production next year
but will we really be able to fulfill
that promise
and we're about to lie
our largest offensive this summer we're
gonna have more than a hundred thousand
troops in the country which by the way
is the largest amount the Soviets had
and we know that they didn't win
and now McChrystal is calling the
offensive in Kandahar a process rather
than an operation which rightly so
recognises that it's not a quick
in-and-out but don't you think we should
have realized that a long time ago in
terms of this war as a whole I mean my
question here is very simple do we have
a plan for winning in Afghanistan or for
getting out safely or maybe it's time
for the White House and the Pentagon to
realize that this is a lost war and then
we need to bring all the troops home how
much of this is dictated to you from
Moscow none of it how much of this is
something that you don't want to say
that you're told to say from here from
somebody that works at RT none of it so
what is I mean what is the purpose from
what you know of RT being around the
world what do they want to get out what
is that a country of rush you want to
get out of this like I said Brian I but
can't necessarily answer that question
on behalf of the entire country of
Russia but I do think that there is a
vested interest for any country to be
able to show that there isn't this there
doesn't need to be a hegemony when it
comes to looking at the world and
there's not only a Western viewpoint or
only at Eastern viewpoint let me
interrupt ask you is it like The Voice
of America yeah you can you can compare
it to Voice of America you can compare
it to BBC like I said you can compare to
I'll just do English to channels like
that and is there as it can The Voice of
America be seen in Russia listen to in
Russia I think so I'm pretty sure I can
but to be honest I I don't know because
I haven't watched it there how many
folks do you need in Washington to do
the job your day and I was first on your
show and then the whole Bureau how big
is it my show we have about seven people
that are our full-time staff in terms of
we come in every morning we have our
editorial meeting that we decide on
ourselves that nobody dictates to us
it's really a very organic process and
that we come in
we talked about what we saw in the news
what stories we saw online we all check
our favorite blogs and and then we just
decide what we think is gonna be good
and what's going to round out the show
that day and we also have then of course
some great technical crew that starts
beefing up the numbers and overall I
think there are about 65 to 70 people
that work out of the bureau in DC now
which is a big change because when I
first started working at RT there was
seven of us total and in Russia what
under what umbrella is it and I read
somewhere the Navasky has something is
Navasky the overall umbrella
organization that RT fits under you know
I'm not good with all those details in
terms of what umbrella over-under
they're in in Moscow we're in the same
building but Moscow has a a really big
operation there they have there probably
10 times bigger than we are here in DC
so you said earlier that there is a
network in Russian and in Arabic they
have arty Arabic and they have arty
Spanish which launched recently banished
what what languages do you speak I speak
English and I speak Russian my Spanish
used to be good at one point but you
know without practice it really has
faded which is embarrassing from for me
to admit because Spanish growing up in
California especially at something that
I studied in school it seems natural I
studied abroad in Barcelona and I really
really took a liking to him but without
practice everything starts to fade I
just think I need to practice again
where did you learn your Russia where
did I learned my Russian not in school I
never studied it cuz I moved here when I
was four and since preschool I've been
in school in the US so just
conversationally just through speaking
with my family and how much time do you
spend in Russia how have you spent over
the years and your mom lives there
full-time yes my mother lives there my
brother lives there my grandmother lives
there so I used to go back probably once
or twice a year when I was in school
when you have set breaks it's a little
easier when you have vacations like that
and now I haven't been in almost two
years
unfortunately because I definitely you
know would love to see my my brother and
my niece and my mother and my
grandmother but it's I find it harder
and harder to do when you're working
full-time did your brother grow up
here my brother was 11 years old and we
moved to the States he's 7 years older
than me and he lived in the US for about
10 years and then he moved back what got
your mother interested in being a part
of the legislature demo you know you're
gonna have to ask her that question
yourself because I was surprised I knew
my mother as an athlete and as a figure
skater all my life and one nation just
told me I'm going into politics
what is she who does what area does she
represent she represents OMPH squishes
in Siberia but she she lives full-time
in Moscow but she's flying back and
forth between homes we've been talking
about your mother and we do have a clip
of you interviewing her on Vancouver and
what would say before we go there what
what is it what are the circumstances of
this interview the circumstances were
that the Olympics were going on my
mother was there and we thought it would
be a great opportunity and a fun
opportunity and we were granted it to be
able to fly me out there so I can
interview my mom on the show and what is
her name her name is Irina rod Nina
let's watch okay so I am an American
citizen I was born in Russia and I have
to tell you that the Olympic Games do
you hold a very special place in my
heart because of the person that I am
now joined with sitting next to me this
is 3-time Olympic figure skating
champion Irina rod Nina and also I'm
very very proud to say she is my mother
now
Irina thank you for being here in Kiana
so first I want to get your impression
of these Winter Games here in Vancouver
so far it's for me not just Olympic
Games and
cause everybody waits and waiting this
begins weather finally like you tell
it's now very good
maybe results for a Russian team was not
so good I think I said worse Olympic
Games ferocity and special in figure
skating did you ever know your mother to
be political but when she was you know
not really my mother has always been a
very opinionated woman believe me she
she doesn't hold back when she's got
something to say but I never really
thought of her as anybody who was
political but I think she's doing a
great job you know from from the stories
that I hear from the programs that she
develops that you know will be new teams
for children or new sports programs for
orphans and I think she was doing a
great job what did you I asked you
earlier where you think you got your own
views how much did her views impact you
when you were growing up uh you know I
can't say that my mother and I spoke a
lot about politics growing up so I know
I you know they will they will tell you
statistically the often your political
views and your ideology will resemble
that of a of your parents and I can't
necessarily say that that's true for me
with either my mother or my father my
father is more conservative than I am
and you know sometimes we we get in our
own heated debate so I really think that
it was my education it was the people
that I was surrounded with you know
living in California I think that there
is a certain mentality to living in that
state and I think that that really did
influence me I'm on UC Santa Cruz is not
exactly a conservative place UC Santa
Cruz is not a conservative place by any
means
what's the happy hour segment on the
alona show the happy hour segment this
it's fairly new I think we've been doing
it for a couple of months now and we
decided that it would be fun to round
out the show with you know there's
always certain stories that don't
necessarily they're not worthy of an
entire interview and entertain just an
entire discussion and they may be a
little more playful and a little more
fun and there are some people that you
just love talking about that kind of
stuff with because you you think of the
stories that at the end of the day
people go home from or not go home from
work but they might leave work they
might go to the bar go to happy hour and
what do they want to share with their
friends what do they want to discuss
that does have some political
implication in it and that's where happy
hour really was was born from and it's
it's a little fun it's a little bit of
unwinding for me at the end of the show
too because I I don't know people always
tell me that maybe I'm a little more
serious in the beginning because it'll
be a topic like I said it would be
something about the war in Afghanistan
and the new strategy what the president
said that day which I just get so
wrapped up in and so it's nice to let
loose at the end of the hour and and
have a little fun and laugh about it
here's a clip where you're talking about
a little bit about Glenn Beck
[Music]
okay it's time for happy hour tonight
and joining me this evening is our tea
producer Jenny Churchill and JP frere
senior communications strategist at new
media strategy
you have your own olives keep your hands
out JP one or more okay so today is the
end of an era and I couldn't be more
excited but let me show you who I'm
talking about there is a strange
alliance between the left and the
Islamists that we're seeing I think it's
all part of the coming insurrection the
progressives want to do in the first
place
collapse the system and start all over
again do you know how much money Rupert
Murdoch is you know he's got all these
things going on you think he's gonna let
a guy at five o'clock say a bunch of
stuff put this together it's completely
wrong and stay on the network yeah
that's exactly what I think is that he's
gonna let you go out there say a bunch
of things that are completely wrong and
stay on the network we already did a
whole story about Roger Ailes and how we
started planning this way back in the
Nixon days but are you as happy to see
Glenn Beck go as I am where are you sad
inside Glenn Beck Glenn Beck Glenn Beck
holds a special place in my heart why is
that because that we have some other
clips around yes Glenn Beck has believe
me provided our show with a lot of
material and finding is now I don't even
really talk about Glenn Beck anywhere
because not only is this program ended
on Fox News but I feel like his
influence has really faded a lot too and
for a while there though Glenn Beck was
who was booming the his ratings were
high and any time I watched this man
this is what's wrong to me this is one
factor of what's wrong with US media is
there's the Fox News model and then
there's the everybody else model on the
Fox News model what they've managed to
do is to whip people up into a frenzy
they work on fear and they work on
paranoia and you have a man like Glenn
Beck out there who and I do think that
people are confused and probably think
that he's telling you news when really
he's acting like this weird you know
televangelist but he's just telling you
that
at all times there is a conspiracy to
take this world down whether it be the
Liberals that are working with the
Communists that are also working with
the Muslim Caliphate and he just goes on
and on or not or not and it's such
nonsense and I think he really scares
people he he really influenced people
for a while and Americans believed him
and I was here when he had his restoring
honor rally on the mall and I just had
this really overwhelming feeling where I
was uh it almost brought tears to my
eyes because there were so many people
coming here and I couldn't believe that
so many people are inspired by this man
that just wants to scare them and pedal
gold to them and pedal food shortage
kids to them he's an actor he's an actor
and people believe and what it is that
he's trying to sell and it's ludicrous
to me and that's why I think people like
Glenn Beck need to be need to be
criticized
speaking of actors let's watch a little
bit of you you know people we are in
trouble we are in trouble because a big
red beast known as China
well it's creeping it's inching towards
us I can feel it in my bones and I can
tell you that oh it doesn't feel right
no it doesn't feel right that America's
power our sovereignty is being
threatened by the East I got dragged it
that's just waiting to breathe fire on
the world as we know it they say they're
the People's Republic a People's
Republic I think you and I both know
that that means they're communists what
are you doing here that was last
Halloween and we decided it's Halloween
why not dress up and do the entire show
as somebody else and that for a second I
think Sarah Palin may have come to mind
and then we decided no no no no it's got
to be Glenn Beck and so that was a that
was probably the most exhausting hour of
my life I was just telling your staff
before he began because it's one thing
to go on TV and be myself every day for
an hour it's another thing to go on TV
and and just act like somebody else that
took a lot of a lot of energy I've got
to admit but it was fine it was fun to
do but like I said I didn't even bother
revisiting that
or the end of glenn beck's reign I guess
you could say at FoxNews because at that
point I already felt like his influence
had died down and good here's a little
bit more of you doing this John Stewart
is holding rally this weekend in
Washington DC I know many people fail to
see it for what it really is now I'm
here to stand up and tell you my viewers
but truth about it this rally is nothing
but a serious ploy a frightening point
to get voters who are too stupid to
think for themselves to follow Stewart
to the altar for sacrifice on Tuesday he
wants voters he'll have their way to the
booths thinking about all the board
polls you and me but they'll be taking
advantage of it they keep the Democrats
in power they're following a man who is
nothing more than a political cartoon so
I guess I'll end this by saying that
Benjamin Franklin who actually brought
us the very first political cartoon
would be weeping if he saw the atrocity
on the mall this weekend why do you
think he was so successful Glenn Beck
mm-hmm
I think that there is a void right now
that needs to be filled when it comes to
television news and when it comes to
media and information I think people are
still hungry for it but there obviously
are a lot of fears that are very easy to
play upon in American society right now
be it the xenophobia with we deal with
immigration or of course xenophobia when
it comes to Islamophobia as well because
of 9/11 and because of all the
uncertainty with the economy and I do
think that people they want somebody
that they can relate to that they can
listen to and like I said I think he
pulled the right strings and he learned
how to play upon those fears and that's
one model that is successful whereas the
rest of the media you see that they're
they're struggling CNN is changing their
lineup and trying new shows left and
right and none of that is working for
them you know and like I said that you
have the the other networks that are
hiring people like Katie Couric and
paying the millions to try to get them
to fill that evening time slot and
firing other people because of it and
that is failing for them and that's
because there's either a void in the
sense that
regular mainstream news isn't news
anymore you don't learn anything from if
you want to learn something you go
online and you can read all of the facts
you can read all of the details you know
be it on an actual newspaper website or
just be it on some type of a blog but
other than that it's just it's just
boring because it's mindless and so then
you have Fox News which knows how to
whip people up and play upon their
emotions and I think that's where my
show is trying to really to find a new
niche for people and that same niche
like I said that I think that John
Stewart and Stephen Colbert managed to
fill for people that they want a logical
argument they don't need to be scared
all the time they know what's going on
but they want it to be funny they wanted
to be sarcastic they want you to talk to
them and then way to talk to them about
issues that actually matter to people
these days I'm sorry but the cold war is
long over for my generation that doesn't
matter we're not afraid of communism
anymore quite the opposite we're afraid
of of the fact that we have this massive
security state and intelligent state
that's growing that is we're constantly
under surveillance privacy is something
that I think is incredibly important for
my generation for any generation but
just as long as long as we carry on into
the future because technology plays such
a large role in our lives and I think
that's why it's so interesting to watch
all the developments and to monitor
things like the protect IP Act and
that's why I go to blogs like Techdirt
and I speak with people like Julian
Sanchez from the Cato Institute because
these are the people that are really
specializing in this type of privacy
security information that is affecting
all of us and we just have no idea that
I think that honestly some of our
legislators don't know what they're
actually writing laws about I think it's
even too too complex for them to
understand which is even scarier you
know you've been very strong about
saying you are an American and but you
work for a Russian television network
but your mom's in the Duma
did she ever Americanize when she came
here and she did you become a citizen no
she did not how do you as you look back
you know what a lot of the publicity
that mr. Putin gets in this country for
instance that the country is less open
than it used to be and all that how do
you track all
I mean are you first and foremost an
American through and through a believer
in American democracy or do you wish
that we did some of the things they did
in in Russia I'm an American through and
through of course I believe in American
democracy this is the country where I
was educated this is where I grew up
this is what this is what I know which
is why I take such a vested interest in
talking about the problems in bringing
them up so that we can address them and
make the country better you know and
what I do on my shows I don't criticize
the politics of other countries and what
might be going on there because I just
I'd focus on America and you know Russia
to me is a place that I have an
emotional connection with because that's
where like I said that's where I was
born that's where I still have family
but politically minded I look at the I
look at the US and how we interact with
the rest of the world I heard you the
other night say the Washington Post oh
how that mighty newspaper has fallen why
did you say that because it has fallen
and for starters here in the Washington
Post and in the New York Times you could
say these have been considered by many
people to be the premier journalistic
organizations in this country but we've
seen not only massive layoffs and a
massive shrinking space especially if
you go with the times but we've also
seen the Washington Post be embroiled in
this Kaplan scandal where you figure out
that it's all a money-making scheme and
that day specifically I can't remember
exactly what it was that was on the
cover of the New York Times but I think
it was Michelle Obama's burger that she
ate and how many calories it had and
you've got to be kidding me
you've got to be kidding me that that is
the top news of the day and I feel like
if you're gonna pretend to be the mighty
newspaper in this nation then you better
cover I'm happy that these newspapers
worked with WikiLeaks at first but the
way that the New York Times says now
turned against Julian Assange and yet
they keep writing stories based on the
information that's been leaked by
WikiLeaks and they play this this very
cozy game with the government as well
where they will withhold information if
if the president asks
- I think that all of that has to make
you start questioning who they're really
working for government watchdog of a
government lapdog
you can watch everything you do on RT
yep
meaning the Internet in case people
can't see it but you can also you have
the RT has an aggressive pitch that they
make that people they want people in the
media to use their stuff their clips and
all do you find people using it in our
media around the country yes I don't
know how aggressive their pitches when
it comes to other people you just hear
it on the air I mean I picked it up I
said you know they encourage you to go
to their website and use the material
because why not right why not have as
many people put their eyes on it and
actually see it and hear it and feel it
as possible let me show a an RT network
promo it's only 46 seconds to see the
kind of thing that they tell you tell
their audience your audience every day
[Music]
[Music]
I think Barack Obama is beatable in 2012
[Music]
whenever government says they're gonna
keep you safe get ready because you're
gonna lose your freedoms
[Music]
[Music]
we never censor your opinions that's
what it said on that screen that's right
I can't tell you I've ever censored an
opinion on the show maybe I've brought a
guest on that I know I'm in a debate and
I tell him to cut the crap but I don't
censor opinions Ilona
that's spelling a ly o na yeah if you
were in Russia how would that be
pronounced it's a Luana and people who
speak English can't exactly say I Luana
and so rather than for some reason it's
just a really horrible pain to my ears
when people say Aliona when they
pronounce the Y so I've just I've made
it silent and that was something we just
happened when I was a kid well I've got
a 30 second promo for you on your show
what do you think about being a
personality how does that feel to you
after you've done it for a couple years
it's well now that I feel like I've
learned to grow in of how to grow into
being a personality and how to embrace
it I really I love it and I feel
confident because I do think that I have
something to offer I think that there's
a reason that people want to watch the
show but at first believe me I was I was
scared so it's a hard thing especially
you know when you're 23 years old to
figure out what exactly your personality
is that you're going to be putting on TV
every day
here's your promo
[Music]
[Music]
how long did it take you to do that that
was you know we had a crew come in from
Moscow with their special fancy red cam
that they had and we really only had a
couple of hours I believe because I was
also working on the show that day so it
it didn't take a whole lot of time but
that promo is that promo is funny ask
anybody that I work with and they'll
know that I complain about it all the
time because while it's aesthetically
pleasing and beautiful my beef is always
that it looks like I just walk in and
say let's do the show is if I don't sit
there and work all day for very for it
but that's just a personal thing
where do you think he'll be in ten years
that's a good question I don't know I'm
going to see where life takes me see
where I think this career may take me I
wasn't sure for a while whether this was
something I wanted to do or not I never
wanted to be on TV like I said in a
journalism had interested me when I was
younger but I wanted to write I wanted
to travel I wanted to write about what I
saw and who I spoke to you when I
traveled because I never watched TV
myself either I never watched TV news
and suddenly when I was thrown into it
you know I used to think the TV news is
so cheesy but then I really do feel now
like there is this void that we're
trying to fill and that people can start
enjoying TV again if you just have
something better to offer than what's
out there
Lona men Kowski we are out of time thank
you very much thank you so much for
having me on
[Music]
for a DVD copy of this program call one
eight seven seven six six to seven seven
to six for free transcripts or to give
us your comments about this program
visit us at QA or QA programs are also
available as c-span podcasts
[Music]